bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver ça
vous regarde version des consignes et
c'est parti voici le sommaire la
république en marche n'a plus la
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
ils sont dix sept 17 députés à s'être
lancée dans la création d'un neuvième
groupe parlementaire écologiste
démocratie solidarité c'est son nom
frondeur ou force d'appoint qui sont ces
ex marcheurs qui défie macron quelles
conséquences politiques pour la majorité
en marche façon puzzle
est ce une aubaine pour le modem
françois bayrou débat et décryptage dans
un instant avec nos invités
les vacances des français seront elles
tricolore le gouvernement semble assez
tenté de nous demander de rester en
france cet été même si certaines
frontières pourraient rouvrir le recours
au patriotisme pour sauver le tourisme
au bord du gouffre est il une bonne idée
l'été 2020 doit-il être bleu blanc rouge
c'est la question du soir et puis et
puis le jour d'après nouvel épisode de
notre collection d'entretien thématique
ce soir le cerveau comment réagit-il
face aux bouleversements du confinement
et de la distanciation social le
chercheur en neurosciences albert
moukaber nous parlera de ces dissonances
cognitives que nous expérimentons voilà
donc pour le programme ça vous regarde
on y va à chaque cvr ça ça n'a pas
changé
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi
lcpc l'image du jour voici donc les
députés qui composent le neuvième groupe
qui a été créée ce matin à l'assemblée
nationale photo de famille sous le
soleil place du palais bourbon à paris
un groupe composé à 65% de femmes en
gestation il faut le dire depuis
plusieurs mois déjà il voit finalement
le jour et il a été baptisé écologie
démocratie solidarité il est co présidée
par mathieu orphelin proche de nicolas
hulot
et puis par l'ex lrm paula fortezza 17
députés donc pour la plupart issus de la
république en en marche avec des figures
comme vous le voyez aurélien taché et
puis on peut également citer delphine
batho ancien ministre de l'ecologie sous
françois hollande ou encore cédric
villani
c'est le bon moment maintenant pour
créer un groupe parlementaire qu'ils
soient opérationnels quand arriveront
les grandes options de la relance et
pour bien mettre tout notre poids pour
que dans la feuille de route à venir
pour la nation les valeurs de l'écologie
la démocratie de la solidarité se
représenter au mieux et vous en faites
partie de ce groupe député eds c'est
comme ça qu'on va vous appeler désormais
cologie démocratie solidarité bonsoir
emilie carillon soir et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous avez donc
quitter le parti présidentiel vous allez
nous dire pour quelle raison précisément
et vous avez accepté de débattre ce soir
avec un député de la majorité bonsoir
nicolas turquoise et à député modem de
la vienne le parti de françois bayrou
qui de fait se retrouve un peu en
position de force on verra ce que
voulait faire de cette allée de ce
nouveau pouvoir dans un instant mais
d'abord le regard de black ops qu'on
commence toujours avec vous stéphane
bonsoir si j'ai bien compris on ce soir
meilleur c'est parti
[Musique]
alors stéphane ce soir autant 6/9 groupe
bah si j'ai bien compris myriam on a
vécu aujourd'hui un véritable séisme
politique puisque le gouvernement n'a
plus la majorité absolue à l'assemblée
alors attention quand je parle de séisme
c'est pas céder vieille astuce de
journalistes qui consiste en pays des
mots effrayant pour capter l'attention
du public
enfin si un petit peu quand même mais je
veux dire quand on parle de séisme il ya
vraiment eu un séisme simplement bien
s'entendre sur son intensité sur
l'échelle de richter c'est comme ça
qu'on évalue ainsi il va alors je me
suis renseigné bac figurez vous que sur
l'échelle de richter
la création d'un nouveau groupe à
l'assemblée est évaluée vallée
considérait comme un celi léger
c'est-à-dire entre 4 et 5
je vous lis a des conséquences de ce
genre de séisme on ressent quelques
vibrations en effet la vaisselle
s'entrechoquent dans les placards pas de
dégâts importants
oui c'est ça résume bien l'ampleur du
csrd a vécu aujourd'hui
oui parce que là où départ on parle
également d'une cinquantaine de députés
qui étaient censés quitter la majorité
finalement ils sont seulement 17 à avoir
franchi le rubicon les plus courageux
évidemment et comme les femmes sont plus
courageuse que les hommes voient la
conséquence 65% de femmes dans ce
nouveau groupe en empêche
a priori le président mac on peut
compter sur la quarantaine d'élus du
modem actions du gouvernement ne va pas
être paralysé en fait simplement la
création de ce nouveau groupe est
presque inévitable c'est y avait une
anomalie en fait dans cette assemblée
aujourd'hui l'écologie est l'une des
principales préoccupations des français
et il n'y avait pas de groupe écolo à
l'assemblée et ben voila voila fortezza
nous explique que ce nouveau groupe a
réparé l'anomalie il y avait une grande
absente à l'assemblée dans cette
législature c'est l écologie donc ça va
être le premier groupe vraiment
écologistes alors finalement le plus
embarrassant pour notre président c'est
peut-être ce à dire que le l'écologie
était censé être un pilier du la
deuxième part de son quinquennat et
voilà que ses propres députés son propre
camp du clac la porte au nez parce qu'il
n'est pas assez écolo
encore une fois c'est pas un drame c'est
pas comme si on est amputé la majorité
de matons de toute sa jambe gauche
au plus on lui a coupé quelques orteils
mais faut quand même faire attention je
vais vous dire je suis toujours des
petites blessures ça c'est un fait ça
c'est la bande à eric c'est là dans des
forêts pas par exemple que ce groupe
gagne en influence deviennent plus
importants faudrait surtout pas ils
trouvent un terrain d'entente avec
yannick jadot parce que là ce après un
bel attelage pour 2022 est un très gros
concurrents pour emma les marques et
bien voilà le décor est bien planté vous
restez avec nous stéphane ya pas mal de
sujets déjà dans le papier de stéphane
émilie carrier pour bien comprendre vous
actes et d'un désaccord politique de
fond avec ce départ ou bien c'est les
dysfonctionnements de ce groupe
pléthorique où c'est dur d'exister dans
un groupe important comme celui là la
république en marche qui explique que
vous partiez aujourd'hui alors déjà ce
que je souhaite préciser c'est que un
séisme c'est une chose mais il faut se
méfier de l'ondé de choc du séisme
c'est à dire que les effets de la
création d'un nouveau groupe
parlementaire ils peuvent être bien plus
puissant à l'avenir que c'est 17 députés
là qui forment ce collectif pour créer
ce groupe parlementaire trouvé qu'on
vous sous-estiment déjà proche de ses
passions souvent j'entends que le séisme
n'est pas très bien cotés sur sur
l'échelle des séismes mais en tous les
cas moi je vous dis méfiez-vous de l'eau
de l'ondé de choc parce que ce groupe
parlementaire il est là pour apporter
des propositions politiques c'est un
groupe politique
c'est hier que s'est pas assez se joue
pas uniquement des individualités qui se
trouve là vous allez dire sur quels
thèmes vous voulez pesé mais pourquoi
alors vraiment voir art et pourquoi
pour les partants de la république en
marche il est sûr que le fonctionnement
actuel du groupe parlementaire ne permet
tait absolument pas de d'avancé sur les
deux grosses urgences que nous on pointe
qui sont l'écologie mais aussi le social
la solidarité
et là dessus nous on considère qu'il ya
une dérive au fil des projets de textes
qui a fait que certes on a libéré
c'était dans notre programme de 2017
mais d'autres femmes y avaient aussi
protéger et protéger on n'a sûrement pas
assez fait alors on a commencé à faire
un certain nombre de choses à la suite
du mouvement social d gilet jaune et
vous l'avez vu dans le projet de la
science que d'ailleurs j'ai défendu en
tant que responsable de la majorité au
sein de la commission des finances à
l'époque nous avons décrété un certain
nombre de redistribution sociale etc
mais c'est intéressant pour vous parler
de ça c'est un peu la jambe gauche dont
vous parlez le social l'écologie on est
dans un moment de crise énorme
le président de la république demande
l'unité et vous décidez de partir alors
qu'il dit qu'il doit changer lui-même
qu'il ya un tournant qu'il faut
réinterroger le modèle de développement
et qu'on sent que le mot de protection
que vous utilisez et centrale c'est
vraiment le moment franchement je pense
que c'est d'autant plus le moment qu'on
travaille dans des conditions qui sont
très peu démocratique aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale les députés n'ont
pas accès l'hémicycle ne peuvent pas
voter sur leur abandon ne peuvent même
pas les défendre
le gouvernement nous présente des
projets le doigt toutes les semaines en
encore la semaine dernière 30 ordonnance
dont une qui commet en cause le contrat
de travail à durée déterminée la semaine
d'avant on était par le concert a rien
dans la majorité gros et marcheurs
dossetto d'ariane section des données
médicales donc sur tous ces sujets là
nous avons une voix à porter aujourd'hui
c'est très compliqué de la porte et je
pense que depuis la réforme des
retraites
on a eu une érosion du débat
démocratique au sein du groupe
majoritaire et dans le dialogue qui
s'était établi entre la majorité et le
gouvernement nie que nature quoi c'est
pas rien les reproches qui sont faits à
ce groupe auquel vous n'appartenez pas
donc vous êtes peut-être libre d'en
parler puisque vous l'observez ici à
l'assemblée
ça fait longtemps que le feu couvait
scouts être surpris de cette rupture
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui peut-être
en tant que tel parce qu'on est ce que
ce que je ne partage pas dans le projet
c'est plutôt la forme le fond je leur
laisse 7 cette liberté là parce que je
pense qu'effectivement ça ça ça couve et
qu'il y en avait c'est compliqué dans un
groupe on le voyait bien nouveau modem
d'un groupe une petite cinquantaine où
c'est facile de s'exprimer à 300 c'est
compliqué et donc je pense que certains
avaient des dif et dynamique ayew ne
peut pas peser sur le fond à l'intérieur
de ce groupe est mieux vaut peser à
l'extérieur si je comprends bien tu dis
qu'on a pu peser à certains moments mais
moi je le dis clairement depuis la
réforme des retraites le débat si elle
rétrécit nicolas sur quoi bon ben moi je
je je je pense pas moi je pense qu'on on
a la possibilité de s'exprimer
d'exprimer des voies différentes
on est dans un skeud je regrette un
petit peu dans la forme et pas le fond
le fond c'est tout à fait je reconnais
que les gens qui sont dans le groupe qui
a intégré ils ont cette fibre là
écologistes solidaire il l'emporté ils
sont cohérents avec les valeurs qui sont
qui sont les leurs qui avait été
rapporteur je le rappelle de la réforme
des retraites le débat s'est rétrécie
sur les retraites
moi je laissais c'était tout à l'heure
madame carew parler la notion de
protéger et ben moi je trouvais que ce
projet mais maintenant qui est
évidemment dont l'écart doit être
totalement rebattues compte tenu de la
situation mais ce projet qui avait
vocation à proposer au plus grand nombre
quelque chose de commun était une forme
de protection très importante très
novatrice à mon sens et donc je crois
qu'on peut y arriver dans cette danse
est dans cette majorité
mais l'essentiel pour moi c'est quels
que soient les choix ces deux
d'accompagner notre pays
dans l'est la crise profonde qu'il a
commencé à traverser qui va être longue
liste sur la manière apparemment
présente la république n'a pas été
véritablement prévenu à en croire en
tout cas les membres du gouvernement
c'est un bras d'honneur pour pour
emmanuel macron c'est un déjà je sais
pas juger 2
de cet aspect là moi ce qui me gêne
c'était plutôt la période parce que les
français sont vraiment en grand de
questionnement sur leur le côté sens et
sur le côté économique sur le côté
social demain parce que tout va
s'enchaîner après la crise sanitaire la
crise économique et puis donc la crise
sociale est là finalement on va parler
de sens et les calages sont à
contretemps car voilà les fans voulaient
réagir ses fans oui je vous disais que
jaune pour k publié un livre bien
connues l'archipel français qui explique
que quand on a beaucoup de mal à se
rallier un point tous ensemble derrière
une seule pensée ses caractéristiques
que l'assemblée a jamais eu autant de
groupe à l'assemblée je pense un record
donc chacun finalement défend non plus
un grand projet derrière lequel les
combiner son propre projet lui avec ses
petites nuances ils sont pas les mêmes
groupes à côté est-ce que c'est passé un
peu le problème de ceux voulant créer un
groupe juste pour une question de
nuances de peau nue et mikari ou la
fragmentation et nuances elles sont très
importantes
c'est à dire que là demain nous devons
refinancer nos services publics
déjà il ya l'hôpital public on l'a vu
combien l'urgence était là et tous les
membres de ce groupe parlementaire un
alerter sur l'hôpital public il fallait
faire des efforts beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus profond sur l'hôpital en vain bien
sûr en vain mais évidemment il ya
d'autres services publics il faut
renforcer d'urgence il ya l'éducation
nationale il ya la justice la justice
est exemple aujourd'hui en france on ne
rend pas la justice dans de bonnes
conditions dans notre démocratie et on a
aussi le sujet de la recherche de tous
ces sujets là il va falloir trouver des
modalités de financement
nous savons d'ores et déjà que certaines
pistes sont évoquées par des membres du
gouvernement qui ne sont pas forcément
celles que nous nous souhaitons pousser
donc oui à vue au jld dans quand on
écoute gonnot le maire qui est une
méthode de l'économie et des finances on
a l'impression que il est question d'une
relance verte cantona en exergue par les
il parle de la d2 delà les transports
les discriminations et contre les écarts
sociaux etc
mais les remèdes qui vont nous être
proposées si c'est l'allongement du
temps de travail si l'allongement de la
durée des carrières
nous nous considérons et nous l'avons
dit ce matin
lors du lancement du groupe que ce n'est
pas en faisant travailler plus mais
travailleurs qu'on va financer ces
efforts de service public
écologie solidarité démocratie c'est un
groupe de gauche c'est un groupe en tous
les cas oui qui a plutôt une à fondement
social démocrate on va dire mais tout le
monde ne viennent pas de la gauche parce
qu'on a des membres qui viennent plutôt
les mouvance de droite mais qui sont
profondément écologiste
moi à titre personnel je ne viens pas de
mouvance écologiste en revanche je suis
profondément convaincu que toutes nos
politiques publiques doivent être
aujourd'hui imbibé d que d'écologie
avoir la vision de la transition
énergétique et c'est raciste et revenir
à l'écologie parce que voilà comme ça
aussi que vous définissez on n'entendait
pas où la forêt est à dire c'est le seul
groupe véritablement écologique à
l'assemblée nationale vous venez du
parti socialiste que l'enjeu n'était pas
vendu par n'était pas mans mais vous
avez travaillé avec arnaud montebourg
fait notamment lorsqu'il était ministre
vous connaissez donc les frondeurs ces
frondeurs ou pas non c'était en train de
nous ne sommes pas là pour mettre des
bâtons dans les roues de l'exécutif
nous les frondeurs shige
ils voulaient descendre le gouvernement
hollandais terrain il était content tout
un tas de choses
nous on est là mais il était resté les
proposer dans leur parti n'a fait et
dans leur nez dans leur part
contrairement à ce que vous faites mais
tout à fait nouveau format groupes
parlementaires pour pouvoir porter nos
propositions
ça veut pas dire qu'on votera contre les
caps de loi d'ailleurs vous avez vu nous
nous sommes inscrits en groupes
minoritaires ça veut dire que quand les
textes de loi vont dans le bon sens
bien évidemment nous les voteront et
nous continuerons à accompagner le
projet présidentiel sur lequel
d'ailleurs nous nous avons fait campagne
en revanche il ya un certain nombre de
projets de taxes qui sont qui ont dévié
moi je suis désolé mais dans mon
programme en 2017
je n'avais pas proposer ce qu'ils
avaient dans la loi casseurs par exemple
voilà donc vous voyez ce n'est pas un
quitus qu'on va donner au futur projet
de texte alors c'est intéressant parce
que quand j'entends ce discours et je me
tourne vers le centriste que vous êtes
ça me fait penser un peu parfois au
modem ni dans la majorité ni dans
l'opposition vous souvenez de françois
bayrou après 2017 qui s'était émancipé
un de la droite c'est possible ça saute
oui pardon en 2007 s'était excusé moi
2007 ça fait bien longtemps déjà
c'est possible de n'être ni dans la
majorité ni dans l'opposition où c'est
un un positionnement info positionnement
politique
non mais je je je pense entre c'est ce
qui est important je suis dit ils ont
fait un choix et maintenant il faut
faire avec ce choix qui est le leur et
moi ce qui m'importe est ce qu'un porte
au modem c'est de travailler au service
de la france je pense que ils ont
massivement dans leur groupe soutenu le
projet d' emmanuel macron alors avec
peut-être des des nuances qui sont les
leurs on va voir dans tous les projets
qui vont arriver il va y en avoir plein
il va y avoir des décisions cruciales à
prendre dans les prochains mois et si
c'est pour faire entendre des
positionnements plus plus que les
écologistes qui font progresser la cause
mais moi je n'y vois aucun inconvénient
concernant le ce nouveau groupe et un
nouveau partenaire on va tendre la main
pour travailler avec eux comme on essaye
de travailler y compris avec des gens de
l'opposition mais qui restent modérées
parfois des députés de d'autres groupes
qui restent modérées parfois chez les
socialistes parfois chez les
républicains
et avec tous ceux qui sont de bonne
volonté et qui ont envie
de travailler d'arrache-pied pour au
service de ce pays pour essayer de le
sortir de l'ornière pas ce que c'est on
est dans une journée très profonde et
c'est ça quand même l'essentiel de
l'enjeu qui soient écologiques et qu'ils
soient sociales ou qu'ils soient
économiques
stéphane voulait réagir le sentiment
était que le gouvernement puisse prendre
des chants des choix vardon marqué à
droite à l'avenir et en même temps c'est
pas très étonnant gordini est droite
gérald darmanin barman et droite le
maire et droite ce sont les les plus
politiques et les plus actifs qui pèsent
le plus au gouvernement
ce que vous attendez en fait à la
rentrée un renouvellement du
gouvernement avec le chef de
gouvernement qui serait à gauche cette
fois en tous les cas on souhaite une
inflexion de la politique ça c'est sûr
ça c'est sûr et certain
après comme ça vient d'être dit nous on
travaillera avec les autres groupes
politiques
moi j'ai déjà au quotidien la commission
des finances je travaille avec le modem
notamment jean paul mattei avec qui j'ai
bougé j'ai posé l'année dernière toute
une série de propositions fiscales pour
plus de justice fiscale par exemple
bon on en a pas on n'a pas eu gain de
cause ni le modem ni moi sur ce sujet là
donc c'est qu'on va là on va les
reprendre dans les futures lois de
finances donc remaniement ou par au
maniement
peu importe ce qu'on veut c'est une
inflexion sociale on veut plus de
justice sociale dans notre pays et aussi
qu'on booste la transition écologique
est ce que vous avez encore confiance en
emmanuel macron pour justement vous
entendre de l'extérieur pour cette
inflexion sociale et écologique ou est
ce que parce que la confiance n'est plus
là on partait non moi on part parce que
le fonctionnement du groupe majoritaire
vis-à-vis du gouvernement n'est pas
optimale en revanche quand j'entends le
discours d' emmanuel macron et discours
de mulhouse sur l'hôpital public quand
j'entends toutes les annonces qu'il a
fait ces derniers temps quand je le vois
à bruxelles aussi obtenir une enveloppe
d'investissement commune en europe
je me reconnais complètement dans ces
combats là donc je n'ai pas de problème
sur les grandes orientations
présidentielles en revanche
donc s'il veut s'il se représente s'il
est à nouveau candidat c'est votre
candidat emile cariou mais le manuel
macro de vous dire on est en demies
je pense que déjà c'est pas une évidence
on ne savait pas il ya quatre mois qu'on
aurait là une crise sanitaire sans
précédent
donc je pense qu'on va pas évoquer tout
de suite et présidentielle donc vous ne
répondez pas à la question ça n'est pas
sûr que c'est emmanuel macron a remis le
cas nous attendons une inflexion sociale
la flexion écologique et j'espère que ce
que je n'ai que jade au louis-ii les
écologistes ou d'en douter pas oui mais
bon j'ai bien fait de ne pas miser sur
monsieur jadot et des mouvements alors
rapprochement tentative nos dialogues en
parlementaires trop la main sur l'ego un
outil de dialogue de toutes les gauches
des écologistes et voire au delà
voilà ça c'est évident au delà donc on
va aller voir richard vers l'est parce
que vous évoquez emmanuel macron tout à
l'heure eh bien il a réussi avec
emmanuel avec angela merkel a décroché
un accord un accord très important c'est
vrai que la majorité ici au parlement la
majorité présidentielle se disloque un
peu mais tout de même cet accord est
notable on le sait il a été annoncé donc
hier depuis l'elysée est depuis berlin
500 milliards d'euros sous la forme
d'emprunts européens pour venir en aide
aux régions de l'union les plus touchés
par la crise c'est un scénario que l'on
croyait inconcevable en allemagne
bonsoir richard wehrli et merci à eux
soit d'être avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le correspondant du quotidien
quotidien suisse le temps et chroniqueur
dans cette émission
alors est ce que la chancelière a réussi
un tour de force incontestablement en
tout cas nous voici face à une
chancelière angela merkel
audacieuse avoué que ce n'était pas
l'image qu'elle donnait jusqu'à présent
on avait surtout l'impression d'une
chancelière très patiente
or là elle va tordre le bras de son camp
conservateur qui n'aiment pas trop du
tout même les emprunts européens pour
mettre en place ce fonds de relance de
500 milliards d'euros qu'elle vient de
proposer avec emmanuel macron et en plus
elle le fait quelques jours seulement
après la fameuse décision des juges de
karlsruhe où la cour constitutionnelle
le 5 mai il demandé d'encadrer très
strictement la banque centrale
européenne alors la dame de fer de
berlin a été remplacé soudainement par
la dame de coeur de l'europe
et ça c'est possible
grâce à la capacité de rassemblement
d'angela merkel alors quand on regarde
la france
on voit le spectacle de divisions
politiques quand on regarde l'allemagne
on voit une chancelière qui malgré sa
majorité relative malgré sa difficulté
aux élections législatives de 2010 est
son parti la cdu ou n'a fait que 35% des
voix
eh bien elle se croit capable d'unir une
majorité de députés au bundestag autour
d'elle notamment du côté des
sociaux-démocrates ses alliés dans la
grande coalition mais également du côté
des verts et tout cela pourquoi parce
que mutti merkel maman merkel est
réapparu grâce aux coronavirus elle a
protégé les allemands et maintenant la
voilà capable de protéger l'europe
avec ce mécanisme qui très
intelligemment sera inscrit dans le
budget européen ce qui permettra au
parlement européen de le contrôler mais
également au bundestag le parlement
allemand
donc on voit le souci qu'elle apporte à
la mécanique parlementaire et
l'implication des députés dans ce
dispositif alors il ya un passif merkel
vous vous souvenez que sa patience elle
a souvent coûté beaucoup à l'europe
souvent l'union européenne a fait trop
peu trop tard à cause de l'allemagne
la voilà audacieuse un peu à la
française la question maintenant est ce
qu emmanuel macron lui fasse avoir
importé d'allemagne
cette capacité à rassembler merci
beaucoup ri cha quand on voit la
chancelière à la fois tenir compte de
son parlement même quand il lui est
hostile mais réussir tout de même à
aller forcer un peu la main entre qu'a
avancé sur le terrain de plus
d'intégration politique européenne avec
ce plan de 500 milliards
on se dit mais quel talent par rapport à
notre président non pas par rapport à
notre président c'est quand même une
faut d'abord voir le fond de cette
annonce c'est alors peut-être que pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ça paraît un
peu abstrait mais c'est fondamental ce
qui se passe pour le pro européen que je
suis pour la première fois que l'europe
puisse emprunter c'était pas possible
puissent emprunter pour financer pour
aider auprès des recteurs en favoriser
les secteurs les plus les plus les plus
touchés c'est vraiment une
un côté historique en tous les cas dans
la construction européenne
alors qui est peut-être à relativiser au
regard de tout ce qui se passe qui
historiens la faire accepter maintenant
cet accord un an-24 falloir que ce soit
les 27 qui qu'il accepte mais en soit ce
serait une victoire de la social
démocratie tout à l'heure emilie carew
parler de la social démocratie je pense
qu'on est tous des sociaux-démocrates et
que anglais la marque elle même si elles
nous paraissent sur l'échiquier droit
allemand est une profonde sociaux
démocrates
ces signes bret révolution pour elle et
c'est peut-être une vraie bonne nouvelle
dans le contexte actuel moi je salue cet
acte de courage mais aussi sûrement la
force de persuasion qui a hué mais neil
mac ronde dans cette histoire c'est
intéressant cette concomitance quand
même vous partez aujourd'hui au fond
alors que le président français réussit
au fond ce que vous aimeriez que qu'il
fait c'est peut-être plus à l'intérieur
du pays en fait mach rouen ne rentrent
et plus sociale à l'homme un coin
enfants tous les casques moi je partage
qui viennent a dit le président de la
république ça c'est un bon négociateur
les équipes de l'elysée aussi et je
pense que cet accord c'est la victoire
du binôme à franco allemand dont on
parle tout le temps et c'est une
victoire de négociation et c'est très
bien qu'il ait mis toute sa ténacité
pour obtenir cet accord là en revanche
ce que angela merkel oui elle rassemble
dans son pays me pourquoi parce que
justement le système allemand mais comme
beaucoup de systèmes parlementaires
européens travaillent beaucoup plus dans
le consensus ont souvent des
gouvernements de coalition
et ça ça vous oblige à négocier ça vous
oblige à discuter à trouver des voies
médianes entre des intérêts très
contradictoires moi je pense qu'il faut
faire ça il aurait fallu faire c'est
vrai c'est un échec quelque part notre
groupe parlementaire devait faire ça on
avait toutes ces tendances
entre nous c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
éloigné du modem on n'est pas éloigné
non plus de certaines branches du parti
socialiste on aurait dû trouver ces
voies médianes
on n'a pas réussi à le faire sur un
certain nombre de projets de textes
parfois on a réussi à trouver par
exemple moi je suis désolée la dernière
loi de finances c'est clairement une
victoire 2
de l'aide sociale mais et la france la
vème république doit évoluer
justement vers cet esprit de coalition
ou de consensus et on verra si avec un
deuxième groupe à l'assemblée nationale
cet esprit de consensus
c'est coalition vont être trouvé entre
le modem la majorité qui sait peut-être
un peu plus à droite et vous même merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp on va parler à présent
des vacances d'été c'est dans moins de
deux mois
depuis que le premier ministre a
expliqué que nous pourrions partir dans
l'hexagone et bien les réservations
flambent
mais de là à contenir la crise violente
qui frappe de plein fouet l taurine
c'est évidemment loin d'être sûr d'hôtes
encore rien ne dit pour le moment que
les français ne pourront pas voyager en
europe alors faut-il se montrait
patriotes pour sauver le secteur l'été
2020 sera-t-il pleut blanc rouge avant
d'accueillir nos invités état des lieux
signé marion becker avec 91 millions de
visiteurs étrangers chaque année la
france est la première destination
touristique au monde et chaque été ce
sont près de 17 millions de touristes
étrangers qui viennent découvrir notre
territoire
mais ça c'était avant le coronavirus
alors si les chinois les américains ne
peuvent plus venir comment le secteur
touristique
va-t-il s'en sortir l'enjeu ce sont 50
milliards d'euros et deux millions
d'emplois alors le gouvernement mise sur
le patriotisme touristique
les français pourront partir en vacances
en france au mois de juillet et au mois
d'août
le gouvernement veut inciter les
français à rester en france cet été et
ils sont 9 millions à convaincre un
patriotisme touristique partagé par
l'ensemble des députés
je crois qu'il en faut vraiment et si la
clientèle touristique française n'est
pas au rendez vous
de ce rendez-vous que leur fixe une
certaine manière les acteurs du tourisme
français
alors on va au devant de graves
catastrophes économiques je crois qu'il
faut une forme de patriotisme à l'égard
des professionnels du tourisme
et moi j'ai mis des français à
redécouvrir le plus beau pays au monde
nikon et notamment les 9 millions de
français qui partent à l'étranger pour
les étés ou sur le tourisme c'est
quasiment neuf à dix mille emplois par
an est essentiellement donc en période
estivale le thermalisme ses 8000 emplois
dont vous imaginez un petit peu surpris
conomique l'enjeu du tourisme dans les
landes
le message semble avoir été entendu en
trois jours la sncf a vendu 140 mille
billets mais il reste encore des
inconnues les plages seront elles
ouvertes
et quid des restaurants des musées des
parcs d'attraction est les
professionnels du tourisme sont dans
l'expectative sauver la saison
touristique c'est peut-être un petit peu
compliqué on attend qu'il y ait une part
la levée de cette mesure des 100 km
d'autre part et c'est un point très
important pour les vacances qu'il ya une
réouverture des restaurants des cafés et
lieux de vie des piscines pour pouvoir
avoir une activité normale familiale en
vacances autre inconnue elle les
français réserveront t-il des
hébergements ou privilégieront t-il les
retrouvailles entre amis ou avec la
famille beaucoup d'incertitudes pour un
secteur désormais classé au rang de
priorité nationale
bonsoir julien aubert bonsoir et merci
d'être là vous êtes député les
républicains de vaucluse
vous défendez le patriotisme touristique
on va essayer de comprendre ce qui se
cache derrière cette expression comment
inciter les français à rester dans
l'hexagone pour l'été et vous proposé de
décaler les dates de vacances scolaires
ouverts on va y venir bienvenue à vous
linda l'aîné soir merci d'être là vous
êtes la rédactrice en chef de l'écho
touristique d'un magazine d'information
consacrée au tourisme et puis via skype
derrière son écran nous attend roland
héguy bonsoir à vous vous êtes le
président de l'umih l'union des métiers
des industries de l'hôtellerie je vais
commencer tout de suite avec vous
évidemment l'hôtellerie et d'un des
secteurs les plus durement frappés par
la crise le tourisme fait face à la pire
épreuve de son histoire moderne c'est
même ce qu'a dit le premier ministre la
semaine dernière vous avez une idée
globale du du manque à gagner pour ce
secteur là précisément après les deux
mois de confinement
c'est très simple vous savez par rapport
au chiffre d'affaires vous avez évoqué
le tourisme
enfin dans les chr va les cafés les
hôtels et restaurants allemand de la
nuit c'est plus de 8000 heures par par
mois dans cette une somme très
importante mais c'est surtout il ya
environ plus d'un million de salariés
qui sont concernées et qui sont
aujourd'hui au chômage partiel parce que
depuis le 14 mars
il faut le rappeler nous sommes en tous
nos établissements fermés donc il ya
recettes 0 pour l'hôtellerie depuis le
déconfinement est-ce que ça repart tout
doucement
ou alors effectivement depuis le depuis
l'annnonce du premier ministre au
conseil interministériel du tourisme
effectivement il ya un grand soulagement
de la part des français sûrement la
preuve c'est parce que or on sent que
les réservations
ça commence à frémir dans les hôtels
résidences de tourisme dans toute forme
d'hébergement marchand mais maisons et
les entreprises sont quand même il ya eu
la certitude pour la réouverture même si
on sait que pour les zones vertes le 2
juin a été avancée mais pas confirmée
dont nous attendons avec beaucoup
d'impatience effectivement que tout ça
soit salon n'ouvre pas un hôtel un
restaurant en trois jours donc il faut
que dès maintenant on puisse
effectivement être être avoir la
certitude de pouvoir ouvrir sa ses
premiers points surtout que derrière ça
on a proposé on a déjà proposé depuis le
24 avril en protocoles de sécurité de
santé pour protéger effectivement nous
salariés est sûre et nos clients bien
sûr et si tous les français cet été
juillet août rester en france
évidemment j'imagine que pour vous ce
serait une très bonne nouvelle ça
pourrait permettre de sauver le secteur
ou même pas écoutés nous on y va on a
fait des simulations effectivement si
tous les français rester en france
on peut imaginer quand le chiffre
d'affaires serait de la moitié de celui
de l'année de l'année dernière donc ce
serait en sort et la profession serait
content toi ils seraient satisfaites
on n'est pas du tout dans ce un premier
schéma là pour votre banquier alors
côté l'autre côté où le côté positif
c'est toujours côté positif c'est que
l'effet que effectivement les français
vont sûrement découvrir leur pays qu'ils
ne connaissent pas ce qu'on sait que la
moitié des français qui partent en
vacances partent à l'étranger
et puis en plus on va les inciter à
découvrir les produits les producteurs
et surtout à consommer facile parce que
pour sauver effectivement j'ai à dire
produire français consommer français
pour moi c'est très important pour
sauver effectivement l'économie
française on va devenir tout à l'heure
je reviendrai vers vous sur les
frontières parce que j'imagine que vous
voulez aussi accueillir des touristes
étrangers mais déjà sur les français
julien aubert le patriotisme touristique
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
l'inciter est ce qu'il faut le faire
déjà bons mots nous on avait
effectivement un courrier il ya
peut-être trois semaines dans lequel on
lisait il faut faire une campagne je
reste en france je pars en france
d'ailleurs
elle a été reprise par le gouvernement
elle était déclinée aussi dans les
différentes régions mais il faut ensuite
mettre de la substance derrière par
rapport à ça nous avions proposé qu' on
puisse avoir des incitations sur les
réservations
par exemple qu'on puisse les exonérées
fiscalement je fais une réservation lé
des jeux voilà c'est annulé un chez soi
les mamans mais si vous voulez pouvoir
pour pour qui une forme d'incitation à
partir dans notre pays
deuxièmement nous avions proposé de
narnia il ya quand même un doute suprême
c'est l'incertitude c'est est ce qu'on
va être dans une saison normale
juillet août ou est ce que ben ali suite
du coran navire usées on voit l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 24 juillet
c'était le projet initial du
gouvernement
ça ne vous incite pas à partir en
vacances vous dit non mais qu'est ce que
je pourrais faire je prends mon
département le vaucluse aujourd'hui si
de l'unesco fermé palais des papes
l'amphithéâtre d'orange
donc les gens d'accord ils peuvent
peut-être descendre dans un gîte
mais s'ils peuvent rien visite et ça ne
les intéresse pas donc je dirais qu'il
ya tout un écosystème de confiance par
rapport à ça on avait dit pourquoi pas
réfléchir par zone
en dix ans puisqu'au lieu d'avoir tout
le monde qui va converger par exemple
sur la côte d'azur même moment essayons
peut-être de faire un peu plus large ou
de glisser sur septembre
ça permettra d'avoir moins de monde sur
les plages car et ça permet la ftq et
nous qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
vous voulez rallonger les vacances
les galets les décalés c'est à dire
faire partir du 15 juillet ou du 20
juillet vers le 20 septembre
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui existait dans
les années 60 ce qui permettait vu qu'en
septembre ont dit qu'ils avaient moins
de risque pour le coran d'un virus
d'avoir une belle arrière saison pour
les professionnels ça marche pour les
touristes célibataire il ya les écoles
qui reprennent les vous savez vous aura
pas échappé que les dates de départs en
vacances ont scellé bouge et que pour
des raisons sanitaires
moi je pars du principe si vous voulez
que le risque coronavirus à courir sur
plusieurs mois
donc on a été capable de suspendre
l'école pendant deux mois on sait
capable de dire écoutez vous partez en
vacances le 15 juillet vous revenez le
15 septembre on sera aussi capable de
dire écoutez on va fonctionner par zone
dans les territoires aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne sont pas concernés par le corona
virus
vous partez au 1er juillet dans les
départements qui sont concernés par
coronavirus on va attendre un petit peu
voilà ce qui permettrait peut-être il
n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui vont
peut-être partir à mulhouse si vous
voulez en ce moment mais en septembre
peut-être qu'on va retrouver un touriste
si le courant d'un virus à des crues est
donc si tu voulais c'est une analyse
plus stratégique et aussi en pensant aux
écosystèmes parce que d'à côté on va
vous dire l'hôtellerie on va la
maintenir fermées bon et puis de l'autre
côté on va dire on va réouvrir mais vous
avez le principal site qui est fermé à
côté et des fois il des signaux par
département qui ne sont pas bien on voit
bien que pour l'instant l'hôtellerie
redémarre tout doucement les restaurants
on attend mi juin on va voir et c'était
très très lent et tout ça dans des
conditions sanitaires très très stricte
avec des protocoles que chacun applique
dans son établissement linda lê n'est
que fait le gouvernement
déjà pour inciter c'est les français à
rester en france on a entendu jean
baptiste lemoyne dans le journal du
dimanche
ce week-end nous expliquer que l'été
sera bleu blanc rouge
voilà exactement jean-baptiste lemoyne
appel à un tourisme tricolore d'ailleurs
le premier ministre edouard philippe l'a
également un dit la semaine dernière
il invite les français à rester en
france a réservé les vacances en
métropole ou bien dans les dom tom
donc c'est un message qui est assez fort
pourquoi tout simplement parce que pour
l'instant on essaye de rester dans du
raisonnable
l'idée c'est de remplacer d'une certaine
manière tous ces étrangers qui ont
l'habitude de venir
et qui viendront de fait beaucoup moins
c'est ça alors l'objectif initial c'est
surtout de contenir encore la
propagation de l'épidémie
donc on marche par cercles concentriques
donc on a commencé par ouvrir les vannes
du tourisme local donc on peut
effectivement visiter son département ou
bien partir à 100 kilomètres à la ronde
à vol d'oiseau en dehors de son
département et si tout va bien un petit
à petit on va desserrer l'étau donc pour
l'instant on reste sur le territoire
français dans les dom-tom si tout va
bien parce que pour l'instant il est
quand même avec les recteurs d'outre-mer
sont autorisés aussi normalement si on
adopte normalement mais y'a frein majeur
c'est pour l'instant la maison de
quarantaine est toujours en place donc
on a du mal à imaginer des
ressortissants français qui partiraient
dans ces magnifiques avec celles
d'autres en quarantaine arrivé avec un
concept respectivement de rester coincé
pendant quinze jours avant de profiter
de leur troisième semaine de vacances a
pas aujourd'hui le gouvernement qu'est
ce qu'il met sur la table pour inciter
les français à rester pour l'instant le
gouvernement français dit qu'il faut
rester sur le territoire il dit les
frontières pour l'instant sans fermer et
explosive qui existe c'est notamment
comme on l'a lu récemment peut-être un
dispositif élargi des chèques vacances
pour permettre à un plus grand nombre de
partir donc le chèque vacances payées
par l'état
tokpa l'entreprise l'a en partie en fait
c'est quand même un mode qui fonctionne
sur sur les deux sur l'aide du
gouvernement est également l'aide des
entreprises
alors on va faire un point à présent je
vous redonne la parole sur les
frontières parce qu'il ya des bonnes
ayez des mauvaises nouvelles avec alex
taylor 1 qui suit pour nous tout ce qui
se passe chez nos voisins pendant cette
crise alex les italiens ont trouvé la
bonne idée pour inciter les italiens à
rester chez eux à rester dans leur pays
pendant les vacances d'été
oui mais si gamme en effet les italiens
ont trouvé le moyen de faire profiter
les italiens de leur tourisme on met d
italie offre une prime de 500 euros à
chaque foyer italien gagne au moins de
quarante mille euros par an pour qu'ils
restent sur place pour profiter des
vacances
sinon suisse il ya l'ouverture des
frontières avec l'allemagne et
l'autriche mais pas avec la france à
cause des mesures en classe au nixon
mais c'est intéressant par exemple c'est
que les couples non mariés quand enfin
se retrouvaient mais il faut qu'ils
remplissent un formulaire pour expliquer
aux douaniers la nature exacte de leurs
relations
si nous avons des biscuits par exemple
entre les danois et les suédois les
soutiens sont furieux que les danois
songe même à ouvrir leurs frontières
avec des allemands mais ne veulent pas
accueillir leurs frères ce candidat à
cause de leur politique d'humilité de
groupe
et puis d'autres pays très officielle
pour l'espagne par exemple avec le
bulletin officiel de l'état avec ses
dispositions et sereine et la lèze
quarantaine pour tout le monde qui rend
dans le pays puis à majorque des pages
entières rempli de rage de la part des
nombreux allemands qui ont des maisons
secondaires se classe avec l'éditeur du
journal en allemand local maillot que ça
et on mayor que vous savez c'est parfois
on l'appelle le 17e land allemand kpd du
5 millions de touristes seront s'y
rendent chaque année
mais ceux qui ont des maisons s'était
occupé des alpes où ils n'ont plus le
droit d'y aller sont pas contents du
tout il avait même trouvé un angle
brigitte alex et oui vous me connaissez
mais rien n'a rien à voir avec le co
ville quoi que personne en parle
justement à cause du coup vite le
parlement britannique
haier voté la fin définitive de la libre
circulation des européens dans la grande
bretagne mais aussi celle des
britanniques vers l'europe
regardez ce tweet hier de la ministre de
l'intérieur britannique pretty patel qui
annonce fièrement la fin de ce droit de
vivre automatiquement travail et prendre
sa retraite phase d'étude tendant des 27
autres membres de l'union européenne et
qui a rendue infiniment plus riche la
vie de nombreux britanniques
à commencer par celle de votre humble
chroniqueur merci beaucoup alex julien
aubert
est ce qu est ce qu il faut parce que
c'est pas très clairs notre position sur
les frontières ont officiellement elles
sont pas fermées mais ces bilatérales
donc par exemple on n'est ce pas que
c'est fermé
donc forcément de fermer la frontière
mais on ne sait pas très bien quelle est
la position de la france vous vous
souhaitez que pour l'été on puissent
assouplir en tout cas voilà accueillir
quand c'est possible là où c'est
possible
les étrangers non mais je pense qu'elle
se serait très compliqué parce que vous
prenez passe dans la grande bretagne
on y avait un allègement considérable et
les britanniques pouvaient venir très
facilement en france alors que nous on
avait la règle des 100 km vous avez les
cas de frontières qui était fermée côté
français ouverte côté français est
fermée côté italien
donc on a on a eu tous les cas sur la
table moi je suis pas très favorable si
vous voulez une réouverture brutal pour
le tourisme
je le suis pour des activités
économiques alors alors quoi par exemple
pour l'agriculture parce que là si vous
voulez il ya dix ans les saisonniers
agricoles pour peut faire des contrôles
sanitaires
ce sont des travailleurs pour qu'on
connaît donc on peut les tester au
départ on peut mesurer le risque ce
serait trop dangereux les quatre
restaurants l'hôtel ont fait de lui la
complexité que nous avons c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes entourés de pays qui sont
peut-être dangereux en terme de cours
d'un virus a plus rien de circulation
l'une des raisons d'ailleurs pour
lesquels on dit aux français de ne pas
sortir des frontières si nous sommes
dangereux pour le reste du monde
enfin très honnêtement le foyer
d'infection mondial pendant longtemps
maintenant c'est les états unis ça et et
l'europe
donc nous le faisons pas en fait
l'europe a fait l'inversé ce qu'il
fallait faire lundi j'ai interdit les
gens de venir c'est pas ça qu'il fallait
faire fallait interdire aux européennes
sortir parce qu'on contaminer le reste
du globe
donc aujourd'hui ils font des voix la
station en espagne et je pense faire
payer par pays on s'aperçoit que ben on
est enfin un pays qui auraient un niveau
épidémique inférieur au nôtre
je pense que la solution logique serait
d'ouvrir disant dégoûté vous prenez vous
je dirais des risques en venant de
l'autre côté de la frontière
en revanche si la situation est pire que
la nôtre alors ce cas là moi je serai
effectivement pour maintenir la
frontière fermée
on va demander à roland église qu'ils en
pensent monsieur et guy vous vous
attendez très clairement une
clarification de la position de la
france sur ses frontières et qu'elles
soient rouvertes pour l'été oui je suis
pas tout à fait sur le terrain que le
député aubert parce que vous savez il me
semble que la concurrence va s'annoncer
très féroce très féroce pourquoi parce
qu on entend déjà l'italie qui fait
qu'il demandait le mode du jeu on va
ouvrir ses frontières et sûrement ses
aéroports de même pour la grèce et le
portugal va suivre
c'est vrai que pour le moment l'espagne
reste assez confiné donc en plein de
monde là on parlait de 80 ans 2000
effectivement touristes étrangers qui
vont nous échapper cette année mais on a
lancé cette campagne d'ailleurs nous
même allumé à l'intérieur en disant
partir en france c'est très tendance
maintenant comment dès le mois de juin
si effectivement l'épidémie est en recul
je crois que les choses et l'économie va
prendre le dessus très rapidement on
aura besoin effectivement de remettre
toutes ces entreprises en marche parce
que derrière je comprends très bien
qu'il faut il ya toujours cet équilibre
entre la santé et l'économie
dayron robles et c'est la préoccupation
du gouvernement maintenant nous nos
entreprises nous chefs d'entreprise on
aurait pu le plus rapidement possible
des marées et des marées l'activité
économique parce qu'on va pas rester
comme ça sourire et en étant bien des
gens ont très bien monsieur guy votre
votre appel aux gouvernements linda
l'aîné sur les fronts
r c'est pas très clair non pour
l'instant c'est pas très clair
maintenant on devrait avoir des
précisions dans les prochains jours aux
prochaines semaines il y a deux mois une
réunion des ministres européens du
tourisme à l'uci laquelle on devrait
avoir quelques premières informations
mais si on reprend les dernières
annonces qui ont été faites christophe
castaner a bien dit on restera sur cette
ligne de crête est finalement
normalement on ne pourra pas sortir de
la france en encourageant surtout pas
les français à certains de la france
avant le 15 juin
donc on manque toujours de visibilité
c'est ça le problème c'était très bien
exprimé par vos deux autres invités le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas
de calendrier
donc c'est très compliqué pour toute
l'industrie de se remettre en marche n'a
pas de calendrier par rapport à l'art
vers des frontières par pas la
réouverture des cafés restaurants et si
la grèce ou même l'italie clairement
appel au fonds à ces touristes étrangers
très clairement la greffe un sas est une
politique agressive c'est parce qu'elle
a eu
elles ont mieux géré ou moins de cas de
contamination que nous ou alors si vous
soit parce que le tourisme représente
effectivement 12 13 14 % du pib
donc c'est une manne extrêmement
importante et donc ils veulent sauver
leur était tout comme la france essaye
de sauver son été après si effectivement
la grèce rouvre ses frontières et
accepte les français y aura sans doute
un principe de réciprocité
c'est ce qu'a essayé de mettre en place
le bouillonnant de nan mais c'est très
difficile vous l'avez vu franck ferrand
greffe et le grec en france c'est ça
l'est moins cacophonie parce que
normalement les annonces devait-elle
coordonnées et phase et on voit que
finalement l'espagne et l'italie ont
grille la politesse à la france
absolument julien aubert ont bien sûr
européenne mais je dirais que nous enfin
il ya plus de dire si on joue avec la
grèce il y aura sans doute en apport de
touristes grecs c'est peut-être moins
important pour la france que pour la
grèce les le nom de touristes français
jr nous on est on al'avantage d'être
moins dépendants et surtout d'avoir un
public français qui quand même plus
riches
moi j'invite vraiment laid c'est
vraiment l'occasion s'ils voulaient
cette année d'aller redécouvrir notre
pays
moi je
j'habite un très beau département et je
ne suis pas certaine tout le monde
connaisse la beauté du luberon le
plateau de sault le mont ventoux
enfin il ya vraiment de quoi faire et
voilà et donc après c'est parce que ses
habitudes de tourisme alors je comprend
six agences de voyages mais ils sont
assez récente il ya 25 quand j'avais 10
ans on partait beaucoup moins à
l'étranger bon et donc je bois araud il
y aura également une autre clientèle
sont ceux qui possèdent des résidences
secondaires qui à mon avis vont tout
faire pour venir parce que c'est je
dirais voilà c'est un peu l'exemple
qu'on cité sur majorque
c'est un peu une habitude annuel est
donc je pense qu'il y aura une forte
pression mais mais effectivement tant
qu'on ne connaît pas la courbe du
coronavirus on peut je crois bâtir des
scénarios en essayant donner le plus de
visibilité aux acteurs voilà et au delà
du touriste croit quand même pour les
hôtels et restaurants
je demandais à la réouvrir sinon on va
perdre ça va être une hécatombe
économique est donc un moment donné
survivre guéri s'il va mourir guéri n'a
strictement aucun intérêt
eh bien merci beaucoup pour ce message
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat sur
le patriotisme touristique merci laurent
roland héguy pardonnez moi on entend
bien votre votre appel au gouvernement
peut-être suivra-t-il d'exemple italien
avec une prime une prime à ses
ressortissants s'il reste en france
c'est l'heure de retrouver à présent
thomas des prêts pour sa journée à
l'assemblée avec rabbi cas thomas qui
nous parlent ce soir des municipales
figurez vous qu'on va peut-être sans
doute revoter en juin alors est ce bien
raisonnable en tous les cas c'est le
scénario qui tient la corde
n'est ce pas thomas où êtes-vous thomas
ce soir à bonjour myriam le conseil
scientifique a publié ce matin son avis
sur le deuxième tour des élections
municipales
je vous raconte tout ça ma journée à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
alors cet avis du conseil scientifique
c'est celui ci 13 pages dans lequel le
groupe d'experts chargé de conseiller
emmanuel macron et le gouvernement sur
l'épidémie de coronavirus donne son avis
sur la tenue du second tour des
élections il n'ya pas d'inconvénient
pour eux à ce que le deuxième tour ait
lieu au mois de janvier il faudra
impérativement qu'il redonne un second
avis quelques jours avant le second tour
quinze jours avant alors comment
réagissent les députés avec stéphanie
des pierres on leur a posé la question
cette dette est la plus raisonnable en
fait parce que qui peut dire aujourd'hui
ce que sera la situation sanitaire et un
éventuel redémarrage du virus en octobre
ou en mars prochain
on ne peut pas des confiner les
entreprises d confiner le métro des
confiner les crèches et exposer nos
enfants les plus les plus jeunes des
confiner les écoles aussi et ne pas des
confiner la démocratie qu'il faut tout
faire pour rassurer les électeurs
ça me parait passer par deux choses
d'abord des masques ffp2 pour les
présidents de bureaux et pour les
assesseurs et un masque disposition de
chaque électeur qui seraient fournis au
début à l'entrée du bureau de vote et
dans sa vie il ya également un gros
point de vigilance sur la campagne
électorale c'est là pour le conseil
scientifique qu'il y aurait les plus
gros risques de contamination un avis
qui interroge jusque là bas à l'hôtel de
lassay la résidence du président de
l'assemblée nationale
écoutez richard ferrand c'est ce qu'il
est raisonnable d'envisager des
élections alors même que les campagnes
ne peuvent pas se dérouler puisque pas
réunir plus de 10 personnes
on peut guère faire du porte-à-porte
masqué si je puis dire sans pouvoir
saluer des uns et les autres parce que
la démocratie ce n'est pas tout votre
démocratie c'est les campagnes qui
permettent des débats confrontations
dont je m'interroge sur le fait de
savoir s'il est raisonnable de
chercheurs civic mairie se refaire on
n'est pas le seul à s'interroger sur cet
avis même jean luc mélenchon pense la
même chose ce vote sans campagne
électorale alors qu'en disent les
candidats
on a rencontré l'un d'eux bonjour
joaquim pueyo vous vous êtes arrivé en
tête du premier tour à la mairie
d'alençon
est-ce qu'il faut organiser le deuxième
tour au mois de juin
foutez moi j'ai pris connaissance de
de l'avis du comité scientifique je
pense qu'on peut effectivement dans ces
conditions organiser les élections
municipales ce sera peut-être pas comme
d'habitude une campagne courte en
respectant à la lettre les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
alors ce sujet myriam il en sera
question demain à matignon à 19 heures
autour du premier ministre où edouard
philippe va recevoir les responsables
des partis pour évoquer ce second tour
des élections municipales
il en sera peut-être question ici aussi
à l'assemblée nationale où certains
députés ont demandé un débat sur le
sujet on en reparlera dans ma journée à
l'assemblée
merci beaucoup thomas comme promis on va
terminer cette émission avec un nouvel
épisode de notre collection d'entretien
le jour d'après aujourd'hui grand
entretien avec le neurologue albert
moukaber vous allez le voir il nous
explique que pendant le confinement mais
aussi après il se passe de drôles de
choses dans notre cerveau vaccinant très
bien je peux l'affirmer mais on perd on
use it les noms n'ont laissé l'un vertes
elle est très belle cette langue bonjour
albert bonjour vous êtes chercheur en
neuroscience cognitive et en même temps
vous êtes psychologue clinicien alors où
se posent cette question est ce qu il se
passe des choses nouvelles dans notre
cerveau pendant le confinement en fait
pour répondre à cette question il faut
qu'on se base sur ce qu'on sait déjà
parce que c'est très difficile de faire
des études en ce moment en tout cas sur
le cerveau on peut sur la psychologie
avec des questionnaires c'est un peu
plus simple et en général les
différentes informations que nous avons
viennent de plusieurs environnements
certains environnements plus comparable
que d'autres par exemple l'environnement
carcéral où c'est très compliqué de
faire des de tirer des conclusions parce
que il ya une contrainte et à
l'environnement auquel on pense pas
souvent c'est les astronautes qui sont
couchés sur la station spatiale qui ont
des skype des zooms comme colère en
train de faire qui regarde des séries
sur netflix qui appellent leurs familles
la différence c'est qu'ils sont
entraînés
on a aussi les personnes les routiers on
pense pas aux routiers qui vivent dans
leur camion défaut à trois quatre cinq
six mois de l'année sur la route et
dorment à l'arrière de la banquette est
aussi font des appels vidéo et idra
et on a les personnes qui travaillent
sur les plate forme pétrolière en haute
mer qui sont aussi confiné en général
n'observe pas vraiment de changement
parce que nous sommes une espèce qui qui
qui est assez brillante en san suu kyi
peut assez bien supporter les
difficultés et même si plus récemment on
a installé une sorte de récit qu'on est
des êtres fragiles sommes traumatisés
par n'importe quel changement
en général au niveau du cerveau ça veut
pas dire que c'est pas difficile ça veut
pas dire que y'a pas des personnes qui
sont en souffrance psychique en
souffrance de l'éloignement social dans
des situations précaires qui ne dépend
pas de l'individu on n'est pas tous
égaux face au confinement j'entends
souvent légende et on est égaux face
confinement pas du tout les divisions
sociales la précarité maximise les
effets délétères qui existait déjà mais
je pense pas qu'on puisse attribuer
uniquement ses effets au fait de rester
dedans
par contre où ça risque d'avoir un
impact cod confinement quand on va
retrouver un espace familier avec des
habitudes très différentes
on va devoir vivre avec le virus peut
être même plusieurs mois voire même une
année ou plus
qu'est-ce que ça va changer à votre avis
même dans dans la relation sociale
peut-être même dans dans nos
comportements cognitifs est ce que cette
distanciation sociale cette suspicion
sur les sur les poignées de porte sur
les boutons d'ascenseur qu'est ce que ça
va avoir comme conséquence je pense que
c'est là où on voit voir plus de
différence beaucoup plus que pour le
confinement parce qu'encore une fois
nous sommes nous serons un peu des êtres
d'habitude et et moi je suis chez moi
j'ai la chance d'être chez moi mes
habitudes ne changent pas beaucoup parce
que c'est à l'espace familier qui dépend
de moi et donc je refais ce que j'ai
l'habitude je cuisine comme je cuisine
d'habitude suis sur mon ordi comme je
suis de demandeurs d habitude je lis les
livres que j'ai chez moi
par contre quand on va d confiné on va
retrouver un espace habituel donc nous
l'espace public mais avec des
comportements complètement inhabituelle
on va pas pouvoir directement repartir
au bar au café dans le métro il pense à
condamner certains sièges avoir des
marquages au sol etc c'est quand nos
habitudes sont vraiment bouleversée qui
a des changements qui peuvent se passer
autour de notre appareil chiché et c'est
ça qui va être très intéressant ou pour
voir comment est-ce qu'on va réagir
est-ce qu'il va y avoir de nouveaux
produits qui émergent pour pouvoir par
exemple j'ai vu une pub sur facebook
c'est pour ça que j'y pense comment
ouvrir les poignées des portes sens du
toucher avec une sorte de clé
comment est-ce qu'on va refaire pour le
travail le premier ministre par exemple
proposer des horaires décalés certaines
personnes qui commencent à différentes
heures pour étaler donc c'est ces
changements-là qui risque d'avoir plus
d'impact que ce qu'on est en train de
vivre maintenant
mais quand notre façon de vivre est
altérée de façon assez durable aussi
c'est pas éternel ça s'inscrit
ces nouveaux gestes d'un point de vue
cognitif sas intériorise cette
distanciation social c'est vraiment dans
la durée ça dépend combien de temps ça
dure et combien est-ce qu'on se décale
par rapport à notre habitude je vous
donne un exemple très basique les
téléphones portables pour tous les deux
on approche invaincus dans ce monde sans
téléphone portable et on a mis un peu de
temps pour s'adapter mais maintenant
c'est devenu quelque chose qui existe
partout
l'ailé les appels vidéo à distance ce
quelque chose que nos technologies de la
bande passante ne nous permettaient pas
de faire aussi bien que maintenant mais
on s'habitue
la différence avec le dogue
déconfinement c'est qu'est ce qu'on va
s'habituer à quelque chose qu'on va
devenir rechange et après parce que le
but c'est que ça ne devienne pas notre
quotidien
ou est-ce que ça va être quelque chose
qui est dans la durée je pense que la
question clé c'est combien de temps
est-ce que ça dure si ça dure très
longtemps évidemment qu'on va intégrer
de nouvelles habitudes que j'espère on
va devoir re désapprendre une fois qu'on
aura un vaccin ou une solution pour le
virus
et sinon bah effectivement on va devoir
créer de nouvelles dynamiques sociales
comme ça a déjà été le cas la différence
c'est que maintenant on le fait par
contrainte à cause du virus
on a déjà de nouvelles dynamiques
sociales pour des raisons par exemple
les avancées technologiques comme je
disais les appareils portables ou les
voitures ou les avions dans cette
période dont on ne connaît pas la durée
ni pendant ni après est ce qu'on peut
supporter de ne pas savoir si on est
vecteur ou si on n'a pas le virus si on
va être testée pas testé est ce qu'on
peut supporter de ne pas savoir quand
est-ce qu'on aura le vaccin est ce que
l'incertitude c'est quelque chose avec
lequel on peut vivre au quotidien
alors justement moi une grande partie de
mon travail c'est sur l'incertitude sur
comment est-ce que notre cerveau réagit
face à l'incertitude et il ya plusieurs
facteurs là aussi qui sont en jeu la
première que je veux prendre cette
opportunité pour bourg exprimer une idée
qui peut-être une patrie commune c'est
que
on a souvent en ronde j'entends souvent
dire que les gens ont besoin d'être
rassurés quand on n'aime pas
l'incertitude alors que dans la
littérature scientifique ce qu'on voit
c'est que c'est très important de
transmettre l'incertitude quand il ya
une situation très important de pas
infantiliser il ya beaucoup d'articles
qui montre que en tant que scientifique
ou les responsables politiques ou etc
c'est très important de partager
d'incertitudes avec des personnes quand
on dirait une personne connaît dans une
situation incertaine c'est surement pas
des agréable mais c'est mieux que de
prétendre une fausse certitude qui après
va donner des signaux mixtes comme on a
vu par exemple sur ce soit sur les
masques on a besoin des masques ou pas
que ce soit sur les élections il faut
confiné mais fermé élections ces
injonctions paradoxales sont très
compliquées donc il ya l'incertitude
vis-à-vis du futur qui est quelque chose
qui doit être communiqué c'est très
important d'être vraiment très clair sur
ce point de dire on ne sait pas et c'est
pas vrai que les gens ne peuvent pas
supporter ça ça c'est un premier pan le
deuxième pan c'est l'incertitude qui est
lié à moi
donc est-ce que je suis malade est-ce
que je vais contamine quelqu'un et c'est
vrai et là on se retrouve vraiment dans
les troubles anxieux ou dans ce cas là
c'est une anxiété qui est légitime c'est
à dire c'est une peur qui est légitime
qu'il faut déculpabiliser
c'est pas une bonne façon de 2,2 faire
de vouloir tout le temps allait bien si
j'ai peur parce que je vis avec
quelqu'un qui est par exemple à g et
j'ai peur de le contaminer cette peur va
me permettre de faire les gestes
barrières pour ne pas la contaminer ça
une fonction les personnes les plus
stressés qu'ils ont peur de cette
incertitude d'avoir le bac ça ou pas
sont celles qui se confine lemire et le
mieux par exemple si moi je suis pas du
tout stressé par le par le virus je sors
sans masque je fais la bise à tout le
monde et c'est là que ça devient
dangereux
donc ça va même une fonction d'utilité
cette peur tant qu'elle ne devient pas
excessive ou paralysante en même temps
dans ce monde d'interrogation
d'incertitude ya énormément de fakes
news énormément de théories du complot
et ce qui frappe c'est que le niveau
d'adhésion à toutes ces fausses
nouvelles et très élevé comment vous
l'expliquez ça en fait plus quelque
chose est incertain et plus sont bons on
a de la place pour l'interpréter chacun
comme on veut c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'interpréter quelque chose qu'on ne
sait pas que par exemple je vous dis je
sais pas deux fois de égale 4 vous
pouvez pas l'interpréter n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté là dedans y'a pas
d'incertitude c'est quelque chose c'est
pour ça que
des formules en mac pour que pour que
personne ne puisse les interpréter alors
qu'on peut faire un commentaire de texte
et chacun voir ce qu'il a envie de voir
quand on était au collège et au lycée et
on est en train de vivre
on est en train de vivre une période où
c'est plus simple de mettre notre propre
vérité attention il faut pas tomber dans
le relativisme ça veut pas dire que tout
se vaut mais sur un curseur mais petit à
petit ce chan va se réduire au fur et à
mesure que notre connaissance de vienne
que nos connaissances deviennent de plus
en plus solide
ces choses vont se réduire mais après il
faut juste aussi alerté au fait entre
les personnes qui adhèrent un des
théories du complot et est ce que ces
personnes vont agir dessus
beaucoup de personnes par exemple qui
adhèrent à la médecine alternative en
temps normal qu'ils disent moi je me
souviens juste à l'homéopathie ou aux
médecines douces et aujourd'hui si elles
ont le kovy des raisons difficultés à
respirer elles vont aller à l'hôpital
elles vont pas rester chez elle donc il
faut séparer
l'adhésion des comportements parce que
souvent on pense que si quelqu'un a des
roues automatiquement il va agir selon
la pensée et c'est pas vrai on regarde
on voit beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
qui adhèrent à plein plein de théories
du complot quand ça les touche à eux ils
reviennent à un comportement plus moyen
entre guillemets il ya évidemment des
personnes qui ça fait beaucoup de mal et
c'est quelque chose qui peut lui un peu
des fois les débats par exemple pour moi
l'impact des théories du complot le plus
grave c'est pas juste sur la santé sur
la règle si sur les relations
interpersonnelles
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de deux
personnes qui par exemple que je suis en
thérapie qui avoue une équipe des
problèmes de couple ou des problèmes
avec leurs familles autour de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine de le
laboratoire p4 de one est ce que c'est
la france qui l'a construit est ce que
le virus vient de du gouvernement
chinois est ce que l'on sait les
américains qui ont implanté en chine
parce qu'ils ont des sentiments l'un
d'eux chinois et ça crée beaucoup plus
de conflits sociaux que de co2 de
problématiques de comportement ou je
vais pas me soigner parce que j'ai
décidé de que ça n'existe pas de
couronne à virus est intéressante c'est
regard un peu voilà multidisciplinaire
merci beaucoup au revoir
humala grand entretien réalisé par
françois chevré avec charlotte est pâle
et quitterie nguyen au montage c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis très belle soirée
documentaire à présent sur lcp avec jean
pierre graff ya à demain
[Musique]